why do you love being in front of the
camera
i think really i became an actress
and a vlogger because
i'm getting the attention i didn't get
when i was a kid and i knew i deserved
it
i knew i had a lot to say and i could
say it in a really cute way
and i knew right away that i was um
uh different first of all because that's
what they told me my mother
said you know in in yiddish it was
uh which translates
to you're gonna die alone um
no one will ever think you're normal
like she'd say you're not normal and i
i'm not
oh not normal people don't have friends
they have cats
i mean lots of them not that i'm against
cats i love cats dogs everything but
i i want to be friends with humans i
also
i want to be able to to work and have a
job
so i have to prove that i'm i'm not
crazy i'm
normal well i saw what my mother and
father paid attention to
the television so as a kid i knew
just be on tv people will watch you
plus people on television especially if
they were pretty
had great credibility and you know after
being told you're crazy you're crazy
you're crazy and in yiddish which makes
it a lot worse
your whole life you want to prove your
your normal
and being on tv makes people even crazy
people
look less crazy and i knew i could
express my opinions
and there i had the audience so it's
just a matter of like
how was i going to be on tv to express
who i was especially since i was a
terrible auditioner i really
sucked i would have been a huge star
if i were able to not lose my mind in
every single audition that i had a line
in
it was funny i could always get the
parts when i didn't have lines that was
easy
but there was something that just said
do it right baby just
you got to do it right and i think i was
trying to audition
the way i thought that the person who
would
actually get the part would do it which
takes every
all the creativity all the put yourself
into it
out of it and i was just trying to kind
and and i was
so insecure i was almost like
every i start every audition with i'm
sorry can i start over
and um let me just let you go back to
your work casting the real people and
i'll go back to
driving back home out of the valley
and when i came to l.a i was 21
uh from montreal my car did not have air
conditioning
and so what most of the auditions were
in the valley and i would schmitz
and i i kept failing at auditions and
and i i was working at um the ihop
because you know working on my acting
skills like acting like i didn't want to
kill myself
at the cashier cash register i couldn't
even make change
someone give me a 20 i'd stand there and
cry you know it's like horrible
but i went through all that because i i
knew
one day i would succeed if i just didn't
give up
i was reading like napoleon hill and all
these like self-help books
because as an actress you get rejected
for a living and
and then um unfortunately i was
me tood into a state of
depression that i'm still
recovering from because every once in a
while some uh
horrible thing will happen uh show biz
related
man related and the trauma just comes
back
you know and uh so i have to deal with
that
daily too so i had a lot of um
very uh negative experiences when i i
came here
not just losing my self-respect i mean
uh i i came here to be on a tv show
um i i my parents bought me a car
where we were living in montreal and i
said thanks
and i drove south made it right at ohio
and then just
came right out here because i was going
to be on this show
and it turned out the show happened but
without me
and so i i was i saw it all happening
the producer apologized and
um i got drunk and so instead of getting
into show business i got into
hard drugs and i got sober
december 28 1982 but who's counting
and so i've been alcohol free and it was
a a a a journey back to
be the reason you drove here hanala
if you were to write a letter to
yourself
on that drive from montreal to ohio then
to california
what would the first paragraph of that
letter be
i would say
turn around because montreal is about to
become
hollywood
you don't have to go anywhere and
then i would say but knowing you
you really want to tan and you want your
hair to look
better because montreal is very humid a
lot of people don't realize it's
a island in the river a volcano really
very very humid we didn't have air
conditioning i learned to suffer
i learned to have a lot of heartbreaks
in montreal so i would
say i know you want to get out of
montreal i know you really really really
really want to go but i
don't think you're ready you're too
sensitive
and the show's not gonna happen
of course she drive here anyway
even if you had read that letter if
someone had read if
someone had written that you would still
have driven
well i i think that i had a real passion
to do this and
and i would uh i don't think that i
could have understood possibly
how i wasn't uh capable
of handling what was going to happen i
guess i would have had to tell her you
know
you're you're gonna be fed some drugs
and then you're going to wake up with a
naked man on top of you
and you're going to make it a joke like
what is this naked man
doing on top of me you know i can't
figure this out
but um it's not a joke it will affect
you
forever and it will affect your
self-esteem
so much that you blame yourself and you
invite
more of the metoo experiences into your
life
and um that it's going to be
a life of a lot of rejection so
maybe you want to like stay home a
little bit longer and
trust me about this montreal turning to
hollywood thing
but staying at home being told you're
crazy from from the people that i've
know that
that's like their go-to line usually
they've come from a lot of trauma
themselves
and that's how they kind of keep people
in their place
from the people that i've met that
that's like their running dialogue that
so would that really be an option
wouldn't it be better to come somewhere
new get away from that
there was i there was a safety to be in
school
i could drink more responsibly
i did a lot of well i was in theater so
we did a lot of drinking
i remember descending this staircase i
had the lead in the play
and uh they built a very high staircase
and even when i wasn't drunk it was high
and so i was waiting backstage for my
first entrance and the whole cast
backstage
they were holding their breath wondering
if i was going to fall and i'm like
oh isn't being on stage scary and
they're like
shh and i'm like oh yeah they're going
to hit my mark
okay i gotta
so i get to the top of the landing and
i'm looking back and the rest of the
cast is up there going
and i'm like where is that i'm so
relaxed right because i'm so drunk
and i i hear my cue i open the door
and i'm absolutely perfect you see i
live with my mother and i was a drunk
and
a drug addict so i knew how to like act
i was an actress i could act straight
so i you know i was already pretty much
of an alcoholic
in montreal when i was doing all the the
plays
well no beef i started uh on the theater
on the stage when i was a yiddish
theater when i was
very little like four years old so i
wasn't drunk then and i do remember the
experiences
and being terrified so i think that
whether i lived in montreal or whether i
lived in los angeles
i would still become a raging alcoholic
and drug addict
which came first your sobriety or
starting the cable access show
oh i started my cable access show
because i got sober on december 28th
4pm if you're counting and i counted
every minute at that time
because i wanted people to understand
what it's like to live without killing
yourself
i didn't think i could get sober i only
got sober because my husband said he was
going to leave me
if i didn't get sober and i was an
agoraphobic and i lived through him
so if he left my life was over what was
i going to do well for a fedex guy to
come by
you know depends on what he looked like
i guess yeah but you can't count on that
no one was sending me packages no i lost
everybody but certainly the trust of
everybody
including my mother unfortunately the
holocaust survivor i felt so bad
both my parents being holocaust
survivors and here i
am throwing my life away but i i did the
best i could
um what was the initial question the
initial question was which came first
getting sober
or the cable access oh right right right
so so when
i was uh well nothing could get me sober
you know i
on my own so when i uh
he threatened to leave me as i said i
couldn't have that so i said well you
know what
i said this to myself not to him i'll go
to one
a.a meeting and i'll talk about it for
like a month
because my mother stretched a five-year
war into a
50-year story i knew how to do this
okay so i i thought okay so i'll get my
stuff together i almost drank on my
first uh
on the way to my first meeting because i
well i i felt i merged better on vodka
wrong that's delusional i no
so i thought it was inappropriate so i
didn't have the drink
and i was shaking like i said
agoraphobic so just leaving the house to
get the mail used to make me shake
and now i'm driving from the beach to
west hollywood
and so i'm like this but i got there and
that was my
first meeting and i sat down i've been
sober ever since that was my last drink
of alcohol
and i thought when i got sober that who
people need to know about this
so um it just so happens i was in a
building
with a public access studio so i
actually saw one but didn't think
anything of it
but then i read in variety foreign
actresses wanted
and i answered the ad and i said listen
i'm from canada
it's kind of like something really
foreign enough
and she's oh come on down so i did a
show
and they all said in the studio
afterwards you should have your own
public access show
oh no now what am i going to talk about
working out because i've become an
aerobics instructor
and and sobriety and i created shape up
la and it was on for 15 years
and then i turned it into it when i
heard about this new thing called
youtube i'm like
oh please that's us on steroids right
so i i said i know how to do this so i
uploaded in 2006
and almost 400 million views later
like so i like i said i knew
one um one pr company uh told me you
know you're
uh we can't we cannot call you a
doctor or therapist because all you are
is like a
sober person with a lot of great advice
and and uh you know what can we call you
and so we came up with life coach in the
80s
and then it caught on so in 1984 i think
it was i was on my first
tv show uh doing shape up la which then
they asked me to be on the other shows
because
i wasn't doing uh shape up uh
nebraska you know i knew where to do my
show
and so i got on a lot of other shows
and um i did movies
thank goodness one of the reasons i did
this show
is because seriously i suck at auditions
so
one time my agent called me and said in
the breakdowns
they want a they want okay my tu
at the time my name was susan stadner
but that's a whole other thing that's
before i took back my jewish name and
got married
but it they said the agent called said
there's a breakdown in the breakdowns
they they're looking for a susan
stadtner type
so he sent me and i didn't get the job
because they wanted the susan stadner
on shape up la not the one who sucks at
auditions
so that's why the show just had to be
the audition i did get a lot of work
like um they used my show starring me
finally in a movie called ruthless
people starring danny devito
and bette midler and a lot of other
really good stars
and i was the person they let me write
all my own lines
like i wrote us squeeze your thighs if
you don't no one else will
you know or squeeze your butt anyway i
wrote all the lines in there it was
about like
four more i wrote that but uh it was it
was a lot of fun to see
my show with a much better set and
better lighting
and as a matter of fact i thanked um
david zucker
the one of the producers directors
writers
brilliant wonderful love you david um
i asked him i told him that i i wish i
had this gorgeous set
from my public access show to shape up
ballet it was all sparkles and colors
and he said well if you can haul it away
you can have it
but like i didn't have a backpack big
enough
or a crew because it's public access so
but um
it was it was an experience to watch
that and then i did a zombie movie i
played an aerobics
star 2 on a tv show the zombie
is so mesmerized he lets the lead get
away it was a pivotal role
more more of the four more kind of
things but so i
i became known as like the actress you
hire
who plays in aerobics instructors you
can see i just let myself go
not right because you never know when
the next job will come up
you